was the last time Chinese foreign
minister Qin gong was seen in public
meeting Vietnam's witan sun in Beijing
at the end of June speculation had been
mounting about the prominent Communist
Party officials whereabouts
State media have now confirmed that chin
has been removed from his post no reason
has been given yet the announcement was
made following a meeting of the national
people's Congress standing committee a
high-level parliamentary body on Tuesday
top Diplomat Wang Yi will resume the
role of foreign minister a post he
previously held for 10 years the sudden
change is expected to cause upheaval in
beijing's diplomatic ranks
this is a huge embarrassment for China I
mean qingham the foreign minister is the
public face of China with the world on
the international stage and it's hard to
overstate the impact that negative
impact that this is having among
diplomats around the world
Chin's absence from
delivery of diplomatic activities was
unusual especially as Beijing and
Washington are trying to stabilize ties
he hosted U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken on the 18th of June but in the
following weeks missed other high-level
visits he was also absent from the Asian
Foreign ministers meeting in Jakarta
earlier this month due to health reasons
officials said chin was known as one of
XI jinping's most trusted advisors
qingang was very much hand-picked by she
himself to LeapFrog many more
established candidates to become the
foreign minister last year so he really
is a captain's pick
um even more so than many other Shi
allies in terms of the speed of their
rise through the Communist Party ranks
at the age of 57 he was one of the
youngest officials to become foreign
minister after serving as ambassador to
the U.S for two years chin was also
considered one of China's original wolf
Warriors garnering attention for his
assertive style as foreign Ministry
spokesperson between 2005 and 2014. the
Mystery surrounding qingang's
whereabouts highlight the secretive
nature of the Chinese government it's
not uncommon for well-known
personalities such as business people or
celebrities to temporarily disappear
from the public eye after falling foul
of authorities but for it to happen to
such a powerful government figure is
rare indeed
chin Enzo term as the shortest serving
foreign minister in China's history
of Beijing
foreign